some breaking news this morning
um the founder of Ann Summers Jacqueline
gold has died at the age of just 62
after seven years of treatment for
breast cancer a family statement has
said it is with unspeakable sadness that
Ann Summers confirm our amazing
executive chair Jacqueline gold CBE
passed away yesterday evening with her
husband Dan her daughter Scarlett her
sister Vanessa and brother-in-law Nick
by her side her sister Vanessa has said
Jacqueline courageously battled stage
four breast cancer for seven years and
was an absolute Warrior throughout her
cancer Journey it's about news that the
founder of Anne Summers Jacqueline gold
has died at the age of 62 after seven
years of treatment for breast cancer